Berlin is not the best place right now
for an apartment hunter there's not
enough rental housing to meet demand the
majority of new apartments that are
being built are for private ownership at
prices that are beyond my budget at the
same time rents are going up and up
every year some 50,000 people moved to
the German capital but last year just
fourteen thousand new apartments were
added to the housing stock
I've come to see renowned project
developer Philip with DEA to find out
what's gone wrong on the urban planning
front will there be any affordable
housing in central Berlin in the future
the most important thing would be to
build a significant number of new
apartments that's where we and other
projects come in and we have to ensure
that those apartments remain affordable
little on the Seba table alignment but
nobody's doing anything about it
there is building going on but not
enough due to lack of funding as phew
there is enough capital available but we
have only limited space to build on you
could build upwards that's the point
we're bound to return to Berlin could
stand a couple more high-rises and
there's still demand for office space
that's that's the other big issue the
people coming here also need work and if
we project the numbers through 2030
there will be no more sites available
for offices and industry so we're going
to be seeing increasing competition in
that sector - his plans also involved
job creation here at Berlin's Tegel
Airport scheduled to close down in the
near future
Philipp OTA wants to turn the site into
a hub for state-of-the-art research and
industry vasya Mahone's and spy we have
two major projects one we call the urban
tech Republic it's a research and
Industry Park for future technologies
the aims to boost the local economy and
attract innovative companies and create
new jobs we envisage seventeen to twenty
thousand new jobs there and the other
project involves five thousand housing
units for 10,000 people the Schumacher
quarter a kind of Disneyland style
future more like Berlin style and I'm
wary about comparing this project with
Silicon Valley because we do have a
different culture in Europe
what we're aiming for is not Disneyland
we want to retain Berlin's mixed
composition its social structure it's
about using new technologies to improve
the standard of living the whole debate
here should always be centered on how we
can deliver a more livable city see you
dance and not how we can introduce more
technology than the eval - not technical
but the objective of the livable city
should also include enabling people to
live there where do they live here leave
one there in the eastern part in a huge
residential area which isn't on the map
no not yet so no apartment here for me
to move into anytime soon it's still not
clear whether the project will actually
get off the ground the site will not
become vacant until after the new
airport on the other side of the city
has opened
you